entré y la ncaa la crisis se exacerba
desafiando el estado de emergencia y el
toque de queda impuestos por el gobierno
la oposición se manifestó en la capital
colombo
esta es una lucha del pueblo el toque de
queda se impuso para derrotar esa lucha
popular y esta protesta es para expresar
nuestra fuerte oposición al toque de
queda tras las violentas manifestaciones
de la semana pasada para exigir la
renuncia del presidente gota valla a
raya paz que el gobierno prohibió a la
población salir a la calle y el
ministerio de defensa suspendió durante
unas horas las redes sociales el
presidente calificó a los manifestantes
de extremistas pero el furor de los
zelandés es es más profundo matizado por
la grave crisis económica que sufre el
país desde hace dos años
cientos de miles de personas hacen cola
por todas partes en el país ya no se
encuentra nada de alimentos esenciales
ni combustible ni materias primas ni
medicinas
en algunos hospitales las cirugías no se
pudieron hacer debido a la escasez de
medicamentos
ser y lanka ya no tiene reservas de
divisas ni dólares para importar los
bienes necesarios para el funcionamiento
de la isla y la inflación bate récords
la caída del número de turistas por la
epidemia de kobe 19 la baja de las
transferencias monetarias de la diáspora
durante la crisis sanitaria y la mala
gestión del gobierno han vaciado las
arcas públicas mientras que la deuda se
eleva a 51 mil millones de dólares